new evidence emerges that disgraced FBI
employees used ugly if not illegal
tactics to entrap former Trump NSA
Michael Flynn while Democrats admit they
want to censure speech and a mother
imagines the lullaby that her child sang
to her right before she aborted him all
of which highlights the defining feature
of modern leftism it gets everything
exactly backwards we will analyze the
inverted perverted politics of the left
then the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
you know those days when every single
news story lines up to illustrate one
central fact about politics today is one
of those days we were talking about the
central fact of the left getting
everything exactly backwards and
actually was Dennis Prager who gave me
this idea last night when we were at the
Prager u Christmas party we will get to
all of that but first let's make a
little money it is time to make a little
money I know that because of my movement
watch with the holiday season upon us
giving is easy with movements versatile
line of watches glasses and accessories
I get compliments on this all the time
this is the revolver style which is
their coolest design it's this retro
futurist I know that sounds like a
contradiction but it's not it's very
sleek very modern but it's got a kind of
old-school design to it I get
compliments on this watch all the time
it's the revolver atlas now movement has
their own mechanical watches it's an
automatic movement watch super cool
they're all about looking good while
keeping it simple they don't tell you
how many steps you've taken they don't
blow up your wrist with text messages I
don't look at this and I see like little
notes pop up say hey you up Netflix and
chill that doesn't happen I just tell
the time on this watch and it looks very
cool movement watches start at just 95
bucks if you were to buy this in a
department store you're looking at four
hundred five hundred dollars for the
mechanical watches even more than that
for the same quality from traditional
brands this is clean design minimal
really quality products that sold over 2
million watches in over 160 countries I
am a client obviously and I'm a customer
I buy these watches myself I'm giving
them out to family members for Christmas
movement did all the hard work this
holiday season so you don't have to they
make fantastic gift boxes and packages
they help giving the perfect gift this
season if you don't know where to start
go over to movement there curated all of
their favorite styles they're in special
gift boxes for you you can absolutely
kill it and you won't need all of that
added stress get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns movement calm
/ co' f fa c OV e fe fe that is MV m
t-dot-com / co f fa c OV e fe fe
movement MV m t no vowels comm / co f fa
c OV e fe fe 3 vowels join the movement
so much to get to today I was at the
Prague Ryu Christmas party last night
and dennis prager gets up there and he
made a very astute observation he was
talking about his biblical commentary
and he said one thing he notices is that
God brings things from disorder from
chaos into order you see this in the
creation you see this in the Genesis
story and what the left does is it takes
order and creates chaos out of order
it's constantly breeding chaos it's
constantly breeding confusion one good
example here is that you know God makes
man male and female he makes them and
what the left does is confuses and says
there's no such thing as a man there's
no such thing as a woman men or women
women or men he is exactly right I
thought it was a great point it occurs
to me this goes further than that it I
mean that that's totally right but the
logical conclusion of that idea is that
the hallmark of leftism is that it gets
everything precisely backwards it gets
it all exactly backwards nowhere is this
more evident than the creepiest most
disturbing news story that I have so I
don't I don't know how long this this is
certainly the creepiest news story I've
seen in months maybe years it is a woman
who is singing the lullaby that she
imagines that her baby was singing to
her before she aborted it before she
killed the baby you have to see it to
believe
[Music]
that separates the living from the other
side
about two weeks before my abortion was
scheduled I started having visions and
talking to the spirit of the child
and they remember in the clinic when I
was waiting for the operation or the
procedure a song came to either
and out of nowhere a pretty little
lullaby
the spirit of that child saying it's
okay
so you may recognize
[Music]
[Music]
I truly felt that it was a blessing
it was a blessing from the spirit of the
baby that she was about to kill to make
the decision to kill the baby just
listen to all this we're told by the
left that abortion it's a simple
surgical procedure oh it's no different
than getting your appendix taken out
it's all physical it's not a religious
issue it's not a spiritual issue this
woman sure thinks it is listen to I mean
the only way to describe it is as
demonic I know that these days in our
very enlightened sophisticated society
we mock all of the smartest people
throughout all of human history who have
believed in demons and the
personification of evil but this must be
demonic this woman says before I got my
abortion I started having visions and in
my religious view there's not much
difference between the living and the
dead they're all sort of the same and in
these visions the spirit of the baby was
singing to me about how wonderful it was
that I was going to kill it
truly disturbing stuff and the sort of
stuff that you read about in in
narratives of demons it would that you
would read about in the personification
of evil so whenever someone tells you
abortion it's just a physical it's just
a little surgery it's not it's no big
deal that that tells that lie that shows
that lie to be what it is it is there is
a physical act but it is a metaphysical
and spiritual act as well and what's so
striking about it is how it gets the
natural order of war of the world
totally reversed obviously we know men
are men are not women and women are not
men the left tells us men are women and
women are men the left tells us that
good is evil and that evil is good the
left tells us that strength is weakness
and weakness is strengthened manly
virtue is toxic and weak and awful it
tells us that taking somebody else's
money is generous and letting everybody
keep their own money is greedy and and
here we see the the peak of that which
is you in in the natural order parents
sing lullabies to their babies to
comfort them and to to lull them to
sleep to wake up the next morning and in
this perversion and total inversion of
that you have an imagined a fantasy a
vision of the baby singing a
Alibi to the mother to encourage the
mother to put that baby to sleep forever
so it won't wake up a an exact inversion
of the natural order I think this is the
hallmark I think this is how you know
when politics has gone totally wrong
when politics and things beyond politics
things in the philosophical and
religious and spiritual realm have gone
wrong as you look at it and you see it's
a mirror image of reality it's a it's an
exact mirror image you hear the left
RFK would say this all the time he would
say approvingly that George Bernard Shaw
said some people see things that are and
ask why I dream things that never were
and ask why not this was a this was the
democratic ideal the left-wing ideal
what he doesn't say is that when the
playwright George Bernard Shaw wrote
those words he put them in the mouth of
the serpent tempting Eve those are the
words of the devil to say ignore what is
ignore reality as it is imagined
fantasies they have a vision of your
baby singing you a lullaby to encourage
you to kill it that is the that is a
fantasy that's a fantasy that comes from
evil and it comes from the
personification of evil and we can
pretend that that doesn't exist we can
we can try to ignore the moral order but
when you see I know that that clip was
pretty long but when you see it in that
in the full length when you hear that
haunting voice that haunting voice I
mean this is a haunted woman this is a
woman who is is certainly not in her
right mind and she shows us that in her
speech and in her song how scary that is
how much at once it makes us want to run
away from the inversion of the natural
order it's it's not always that
spiritually clear there are also comedic
versions there are also light versions
of the left inverting the natural order
so Sports Illustrated every year gives
away its inspiration of the Year award
and this year it's giving it to Rachel
den Hollander who was she was the first
woman to publicly accuse the US
gymnastics dr. Larry Nasser of sexually
abusing her Larry Nasser amused scores
of other women and so she's winning the
award who is Sports Illustrated picking
to give this award out to
Rachele den Hollander I'll I'll let you
see for yourself
good evening I am honored to speak with
you from afar about a woman I admire so
much a woman who suffered abuse as a
vulnerable teenaged athlete who found
the courage to talk publicly to stop the
abuse of others her courage inspired
other survivors to end their silence and
we all know the result
Rachel Dunn Hollander I am in all of you
and I will always be inspired by you I'm
stepping forward you took a huge risk
and you galvanized future generations to
come forward even when the odds are
seemingly stacked against them the
lasting lesson is that we all have the
power to create real change and we
cannot allow ourselves to be defined by
the acts of others ladies and gentlemen
please welcome this year's Sports
Illustrated inspiration of the Year
Rachel
den Hollander I am a totally normal
person who doesn't have any designs on
getting famous or making money I'm just
a normal regular person without a crazy
creepy voice who doesn't constantly seek
the cameras in the spotlight what it
what a terrifying video be also because
the video it's Tara you know it's
terrifying at least in a comedic way
it's not terrifying in the way of that
that previous video of the woman singing
that perverse lullaby but this is
terrifying in a in a way that that mocks
the obliviousness of this woman so if
you couldn't see it
the camera keeps cutting in and out and
these really weird cuts and the reason
it has these weird cuts is probably she
needed to do multiple takes of this but
I hope that this video I hope the good
thing that comes out of Sports
Illustrated picking Brett Cavanaugh's
accuser Christine Blais afford to
present this award I hope that this
dispels the ridiculous fiction that this
is just a woman who wants to tell her
story and she doesn't want Fame she
doesn't want money
she doesn't want adulation she just
wants to she it was so hard for her to
tell her story
bs total BS I don't know if she's a
lunatic or a liar but she's one of those
two things we know that she contradicted
her story countless times first there
were four people in the room then there
were two people in the room everybody
who she named as being there including
her lifelong fat friend this this female
friend of hers said that it didn't
happen she never met Brett Kavanaugh it
didn't happen in her life it's Ford kept
changing her story to make it more
convenient and in the line that
everybody said to defend her was what
does Christine Ford have to gain from
this what on earth could she game I
don't know a lot of Fame she's got a ton
of celebrity she's now a salute is
virtually a celebrity it's not that she
did anything to deserve it other than
going and testifying against a good man
she's also gained a number of book deal
offers it's unclear who she's gonna go
with but a lot of offers that can be
very lucrative and she gained eight
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
GoFundMe campaigns so I don't know she
gained nearly a million bucks she got a
bunch of Fame and she's now got her own
little career out of this and the
adulation of the crowds that's what
she's got
so everybody now chart what what an
inspiration Christine Blasi for it is
Christine Ford a fraud either a fraud or
a liar or a lunatic or some combination
of the three demonstrably so
contradicted her lines contradicted by
the people who see she said could
corroborate it she is now given the
spotlight over this girl Rachel den
Hollander who actually is an inspiration
who actually did go out and blow the
whistle on this guy Larry Nasser and get
him thrown in the clink she is the
inspiration but the left completely
flips it and now we've got this fraud
who who makes light of people who have
actually suffered sexual abuse because
she made up some ridiculous story from
35 or 36 or 37 years ago we don't know
cuz she doesn't know the date that
either happened here or there somewhere
it might have involved this guy or that
guy or who knows where a guy allegedly
pushed her onto a bed that totally makes
light it totally takes away and detracts
from people who have actually suffered
sexual abuse like the gymnasts of the
hand of Larry Nasser it only gets worse
from there
fine let's let's take a little reprieve
let's have a little moment of levity and
niceness here to talk about blinds.com
because window treatments are one of
those things that yeah I just don't I
hear it my eyes glaze over
sort of look you know the staring out of
the window you don't even think about
your blinds unless you move or unless
your blinds break when they're right
everything in your home looks better it
sets off everything when they're wrong
everything in your home looks cheap and
like you don't know how to decorate but
you're not going to take the time to
pick out and buy the blinds that sounds
very expensive it's kind of boring you
don't install them yourself blind Satcon
makes it really easy for you if you're
not sure what you want or you're not
even sure where to start
blinds calm we'll give you a free online
design consultation you send them
pictures of your house they will send
you back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture and specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to make sure everything looks as good in
person as it does online and every order
gets free shipping best part if you
accidentally miss measure or pick the
wrong color if you mess it up blinds.com
will remake your blinds for free for a
limited time this is my Christmas
present to you you get 20% off
everything at blinds.com when you use
the promo code Michael mi CH AE l a
before E except after C well tab I don't
know
Michael mi CH AE l blinds.com promo code
michael 20% off everything faux wood
blinds cellular shades roller shades and
more blinds con promo code michael mi CH
AE l rules and restrictions apply so -
you have two spectra here your two ends
of the same spectrum you've got this
insane case of the abortion lullaby
you've got the frivolous and ridiculous
case of Christine Ford now we get into
the nuts and bolts of politics and how
things go exactly wrong we now have
pretty decent evidence that the FBI
entrapped Michael Flynn Michael Flynn
the national security adviser for Donald
Trump the FBI got him to make a Mis
statement to them about his interactions
with the Russian ambassador to the US
who he was perfectly entitled to talk to
as part of his job to talk to this guy
they got him to make a false statement
they forced him into a plea deal into a
saying that he did it
pleading guilty and now it's looking
like everything that led up to that was
a was a big ugly campaign
Andy McCabe the disgraced FBI agent this
is all under James Comey by the way
James Comey was still the FBI director
James Comey who says that he has ethical
leadership that's his in his Twitter bio
ethical leadership and just listen to
how unethical all of this was Andy
McCabe disgraced FBI agent booted out of
the agency and disgrace he calls up
Michael Flynn Michael Flynn national
security adviser he says hey I got some
FBI agents want to talk to you look you
really shouldn't bring that White House
Counsel around you and that's just gonna
if you bring a lawyer around he's just
gonna mess everything up just you know
they're gonna sit down with you it's no
big deal
so Flynn stupidly says that he's willing
to do this
who does he send over he sends over
Peter struck that crooked FBI agent the
lover boy who was texting how he was
going to undo the presidential election
prevent Trump from becoming president
texting that to his adulterous lover
Lisa Paige so so Peter strut goes over
there and he entraps
Michael Flynn in lies he had already
seen Michael Flynn's conversations with
the Russian ambassador how had he seen
them because the Obama administration
unmasked those conversations with the
Obama administration's spying on the
Trump campaign spying on private
Americans Peter struck had already seen
that and he gets Michael Flynn to make
some Mis statements to the FBI worth
remembering nothing wrong at all with
Michael Flynn talking to this ambassador
and so what Michael Flynn says is he
made those Mis statements because he
misremembered what had been discussed
but maybe Flynn's lying maybe that's
true I don't know I I could certainly
miss state plenty of conversations that
I've had on the phone
the reason we know this is a big deal
the reason we know that this corruption
and these ugly tactics are finally
coming to light you gotta remember Peter
struck dismissed from the Russia
investigation in disgrace
Andy McCabe dismissed from the FBI in
disgrace at the time that Flynn is
giving this this conversation with the
FBI agents it's not even public that
there is a Russia investigation to begin
with
judge Emmett Sullivan who's apparently a
pretty straight shooter is now demanding
the documents that that were related to
Michael Flynn's interview he's demanding
it to see if the FBI used ugly dirty
possibly illegal tactics to entrap this
guy in making a false statement we'll
see I am Mike what they did to Michael
Flynn was awful why did he plead guilty
well he doesn't have a lot of money
Michael Flynn just serviced
spend almost all of his career in the
public sector serving our country as a
three-star general he they were
threatening to go after his son they
were threatening to embroil him in legal
battles would have bankrupted him so he
he pleads guilty to this he probably
shouldn't have but I hope that President
Trump
pardons him I hope he gets a full pardon
it was disgusting how the investigation
began the people who did it were corrupt
to their core all the way up to James
Comey and he should be pardoned for it
this is this is the bad news for
president Trump today
the good news though is we're talking
about the wall we've been encouraging
President Trump to shut down the
government and get the money to build
the wall so President Trump just tweeted
out he said quote I often stated one way
or the other Mexico is going to pay for
the wall this has never changed our new
deal with Mexico and Canada the u.s. MCA
is so much better than the old very
costly and anti USA nafta deal that just
by the money we say if Mexico is paying
for the wall okay okay that's fine it
may be the u.s. is gonna get a lot more
money because of this may be tax
receipts to the government will increase
maybe whatever okay that's fine he's
trying to twist it around again nobody
cares if Mexico actually pays for the
wall the wall is not that expensive we
just wanted to be built we have a record
high number of illegal aliens crossing
over 3,000 a day right now we just want
the damn wall to be built and hopefully
President Trump will do that before
Nancy Pelosi takes over leadership of
the House of Representatives but what I
what I actually want to point to in this
is the name of the trade deal you all
know NAFTA the North American Free Trade
Agreement the new one is called the u.s.
MCA the u.s. Mexico Canada Agreement now
I was reading some commentary on this
and I noticed left wingers hate the new
name got left winger writing on media
said that he hates us MCA we should just
call it noon afternoon afta is so much
better but listen there's actually a
very subtle but important distinction
here the u.s. MCA is the better name
because it acknowledges what the trade
agreement actually is the trade
agreement is an agreement between the
United States Mexico and Canada three
distinct nations three sovereign nations
who are deciding to have a certain trade
regime with one another
compare that to NAFTA the North American
Free Trade Agreement as though there is
some overarching political entity called
the North American government the North
American Federation the North American
whatever that is governing this trade
between I don't know the North America
people the North Americans it's a subtle
distinction but it's an important one
and it's how the Left gets these things
backwards the point of the free trade
agreement is to make all of these
countries better to make them stronger
to make them more prosperous to make
them more equitable and just to make to
strengthen all three countries u.s.
Mexico and Canada the the idea behind
NAFTA is to invert that to diminish the
importance of the individual countries
and to have trade for the sake of trade
to wipe away these national distinctions
it's backwards and the Trump
administration I don't know who came up
with a name but they get that exactly
right that's a subtle point but it's
very good they get it they get it in the
correct order they don't flip it around
the left by the way just just in the
last day has tipped its hand on its
inversion of free speech as well here is
ted Lieu one of my favorite democrat
he's not quite as good as alexandria
Ocasio cortez but he says pretty stupid
things as well he's pretty close he's up
there
here is ted Lieu on CNN describing his
view of free speech i would love to be
able to regulate the content of speech
the first moment prevents me from doing
so and that's simply a function of the
First Amendment but I think over a long
run it's better that government does not
regulate the content of speech I would
urge these private sector companies to
regulate it better themselves but it's
really nothing that I believe government
can do and so that's been my position
all along okay three things here one
what does he literally say he literally
says I would love to regulate the
content of speech which is a great I
can't wait for every Republican to chop
that up with that in their commercials
for 2020 it's gonna look really good Ted
Lou's primary opponents or rather his
general election opponents are certainly
going to use that because that is what
he said now - what is the point he's
trying to make the point that he thinks
he's making is we all want to regulate
everybody's speech I don't want you to
say this you don't want me to say that
and the government shouldn't regulate
speech because you want to regulate my
speech I want to regulate your speech so
the government shouldn't regulate speech
and therefore private companies should
regulate speech because we all
ultimately want to regulate speech that
is what he thinks he's saying that's
what he's trying to say that's the most
generous version of what he's saying and
it's totally backwards it gets it
exactly wrong I don't want to regulate
speech I don't want to regulate what Ted
Lou says I want ted Lieu to go on CNN
and spout his inanity all the time it
makes it easier to write my show it
gives me a lot of lols and I'm here for
the lulz so fine by me he can do
whatever he wants he he genuinely
expressing the true view of the left
thinks that we all want to regulate that
speech but so he's saying the government
shouldn't regulate speech it's
unconstitutional for the for the
government to regulate speech therefore
the companies should but what I'm saying
is I don't want to regulate speech it's
unconstitutional the government should
not regulate speech and therefore
private companies even though they may
regulate speech in many instances should
not because it cuts against the ethos of
the American nation and of the American
project and of our principles and of our
traditions and of our constitutional
underpinning of our entire country so
therefore the private companies should
follow our traditions and not regulate
speech ted Lieu says because we can't
regulate speeches of government
therefore the private company should
it's a perfect inversion it gets it
exactly wrong we have to get to the most
egregious story the most egregious story
of the last two weeks it's about that
attack in Strasbourg a Muslim terrorist
came out and killed people in the
streets at a Christmas market right
around Christmas time shouting Allahu
Akbar the takbir the the saying that
Muslim terrorists say right before they
kill a lot of people and CNN responded
to that by running a piece titled what
Allahu Akbar really means and blaming
everyone else for misinterpreting it we
will explain what Allahu Akbar really
really means we got to do that after the
break plus we have the mailbag coming up
so if you're on daily wire.com you're
right there thank you
you keep COFA in my cup you keep the
lights on if you're not go to daily
wire.com you get me you get the intro
claim I'm sure you get the Ben Shapiro
sure you get the Mount wall sure you get
that question the mailbag your dad's
question in the conversation your desk
questions on backstage you get a ton of
you get another Kingdom you get
everything we are like the biggest
studio in Hollywood right now operating
out of this Tora Bora cave that we're in
but none of that matters what really
matters is the leftist tears tumblr it's
so important you need at this holiday
season because pretty soon the weather
is getting colder you're going to not
have leftist tears rain drops you're
gonna have leftist tears snowflakes and
everyone knows snow is fluffier and and
we're has more volume than water does so
you're gonna drown you're gonna
suffocate in an avalanche you need the
leftist tears tumblr to just take it all
in it's the only FDA approved vessel go
to daily wire comm we'll be right back
with Allahu Akbar in the mailbag
a terrorist attack in Strasbourg Muslim
terrorist screams Allahu Akbar kills two
people leaves another one brain-dead
injures a bunch more on the run and CNN
responds by defending the phrase Allahu
Akbar here's how they begin contrary to
what many people seem to think the words
Allahu Akbar simply mean God is greater
it is a powerful declaration used by
Muslims on many occasions and in many
prayers it is a celebration of life I
can't even get through this without
laughing the first words father's
whisper in the ears of their newborns
they are used to indicate gratitude when
God bestows something upon you that you
would have been incapable of taining
were it not for divine benevolence I
assume he means his enemies decapitated
heads maybe not he goes on it is a
prayerful phrase that reminds us that no
matter what our concerns may be God is
greater than them okay God is greater
than them that's actually a true
statement this is a constant canard that
we hear on the left because what the
left does is they defend the literal
phrase God is greater God God is greater
than what Allah is greater than what
they don't finish that statement but
just on the okay sure to say God is
great of course of course we all defend
that of course absolutely right but how
is the phrase used and how tone-deaf is
this a Muslim terrorist has just
shrieked this phrase before killing
people as has happened now 70 times in
Europe just in Europe in just the last
two years countless more times around
the world and in previous years we know
that in Europe right now they have five
and a half million largely unvetted
Muslim migrants who have come in between
2010 and 2016 this is obviously
increased this problem this massive
widespread problem of Islamic terrorism
why are they all yelling Allahu Akbar
with this CNN article would have us
believe is oh that people don't use that
in terrorist attacks no it's a
celebration of life no it's not this it
has that's a fringe it has nothing to do
with that the takbir the Allahu Akbar is
a battle cry that is its earliest usage
the earliest use oh we
we know the modern usages the hijacker
Mohammed Atta from the 9/11 terrorist
attacks had a checklist on him the
checklist included yelling Allahu Akbar
right when the attacks began the the
flight 93 you could hear them yelling
Allahu Akbar as the plane went all the
way down the first time it was used it
was used by Mohammed the founder of the
Islamic religion it was used by him
during the Battle of Badr in 624 it
wasn't used when he was greeting his
newborn child it wasn't used in moments
celebrating life it was used in battle
at the Battle of Badr in the early 7th
century by Muhammad himself the CNN
piece goes on worshipers at a mosque in
Quebec reportedly heard the phrase
Allahu Akbar the very phrase they recite
in morning prayers uttered by their
white supremacist attacker just before
he opened fire and killed six Muslims in
January and Muslims at a mosque in
Minnesota were reciting a lot Akbar
during their morning prayers when their
mosque was fire bombed in August is
allahu akbar sometimes used as a battle
cry yes though senator john mccain has
argued on fox news that does not make
the phrase itself abhorrent
well noting that moderate muslims also
say allahu akbar mccain said the phrase
is no more troubling than a christian
saying thank God except it is because
thank God is not a battle cry that's
it's not a battle cry Christians don't
say thank God
well they commit terrorist attacks
doesn't happen that's not how it works
it is totally different
he's Allah ho Akbar sometimes used as a
battle cry yes from it's from the very
earliest usage that we know of it now
have white supremacists attacked Muslims
yes is that bad yes should they not do
it of course they shouldn't of course
not notice they can't even say
Christians because these guys who
attacked those mosques were not
Christians and were they they were using
allahu akbar as a battle cry then which
is they were using the battle cry
ironically when they were attacking
these people of course those people
should be condemned but how obtuse for
CNN just as a Muslim terrorists in
Strasbourg kills people on the run to
mention the vanishingly few number of
white supremacist attacks on mosques and
on Muslims you say well what about that
that is the definition of what about ISM
what about
70 Muslim terrorist attacks in the last
two years in Europe what about the
thousands of terrorist attacks around
the world in just the last 25 years 28
years since 9/11 what about those how
obtuse to point that out what what the
left wants to do though this is the
perfect example of them inverting
reality is they want to make Islam into
Christianity they want to turn
Christianity into Islam but there is a
fundamental difference they want to say
but you hear this all the time from
generally left-wing politicians they say
Islam is the religion of peace Islam is
well know Christianity is a religion of
peace that's true Islam is not one in
Christianity you have Christ say turn
the other cheek pray for those who
persecute you in Islam you say find your
enemies where they pray and hack at
their necks and be not friends with the
Jews of the Christians for they are each
other's friends don't take my word for
it Barak Obama thought it was up to him
to describe what the Islamic religion
really said a contrary to Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi the head of Isis who holds a
PhD in Islamic theology from Baghdad I
know there no you we don't get to
forcibly change a religion we don't get
to make Islam into Christianity or
Christianity into Islam as the CNN
article wants to do there is a
fundamental difference between those two
religions which is the question of
voluntourism volunteerism is the
philosophical notion that the will is
primary that my will and my willing
things to happen is primary so in
Christianity our is God is a God of will
and intellect our God is the word is the
logos is the divine logic of the
universe the God of Islam Allah is a God
of pure will don't take my word for it
take it from some of the greatest
Islamic theologians the medieval Islamic
theologian eben Hazem says God is not
bound even by God's own word nothing
would oblige God to reveal the truth to
us and if it were God's will God could
even will us to practice idolatry
because he is pure will he is not
answerable or bound by logic the Pope
Benedict the sixteenth laid this out
marvelously in one of the great oceans
of our modern era the Regensburg address
voluntourism is the issue here
or are we bound by a logic is God the
divine logic of the universe or is there
simply will pure will opposed to logic
volunteerism is not just a question of
Islam versus Christianity volunteerism I
think is the primary cause of our
cultural confusion today is that it is
the definition of self definition it is
to say there is no logic that I am
answerable to there is no the truth
there is only my truth and my will
forcing myself definition you say by all
lights of logic that I am a man but I
say that I am a woman I will myself to
be a woman in the face of all logic that
is what volunteerism is our historic
religion in the West our religion that
our culture is based on worships of God
who is not pure will but who is divine
logic there is a huge movement led by
the left today to undercut that line to
undercut the notion of truth of
objectivity of moral standards of
mathematical standards of biological
realities who says that some people see
things that are and ask why but I dream
of things that never were and ask why
not there is a world of reality and
there is a world of fantasy of a fantasy
that inverts and perverts that reality
we have to reject that we must reject
that fantasy it leads to horrific
outcomes because we are lit we are
living in the world we are living in
truth if you follow the truth the truth
will set you free but if you follow
fantasy you will only drive yourself
into madness now let's get to the
mailbag I know we're gonna be running
late but I'm gonna burn through all
these questions from Paulson to the
Catholic one who writes better books
than the Jewish one why do we use the
name Jesus as opposed to Yeshua Yeshua
being the Hebrew word for Jesus I've
heard some rather conspiratorial ideas
about it from people who use the Hebrew
name they'll say pagans did it so that
it they could pray to Zeus I just was
wondering if you could clear that up
yeah some people are very confused about
this the the word for Jesus in he
is Yeshua or yasou and this is related
to Joshua and but the reason that we get
Jesus out of that is because when you
translate Yeshua into Greek you get ya
Zeus and in Latin ya Zeus j esus the J
is pronounced yeh and from that we get
Jesus when we anglicize it so it's not
anything about Zeus you're not praying
to some pagan deity it is simply the
translation of Yeshua into our languages
and that's perfectly fine because in
Christ there is no Jew nor Greek slave
nor bond nor male nor woman but all or
one in Christ Jesus and so we can
translate his name just fine and he's
the same guy from Michael Michael I hate
to continue bringing up baby it's cold
outside ad nauseam but I have a separate
take on it I find that there are two
camps one that says it promotes rape and
another that it's a wonderful song that
should be celebrated I find the lyrics
to the song while not a rape song is
certainly about promiscuous behavior and
almost certainly outside the context of
marriage shouldn't we find the song to
be morally objectionable on those
grounds thanks so much Michael
well it's promiscuous certainly but is
your suggestion that pop music is
promiscuous oh heavens
grab my pearls oh no that's just the way
it is and it's it's not necessarily
promiscuous get your head out of the
gutter it may I don't know what they did
when he convinced her to stick around
all we know is you've got a man and a
woman canoodling by the fire and the
woman is teasing the man and saying oh I
really should go because my mother's
gonna wonder where I am I really
shouldn't stay here by this cozy fire
and canoodle with my little honey and
then the guy says oh please let me
seduce you please stick stick around but
I don't know they might have just canoe
told maybe maybe necked maybe kissed in
the French way oh you don't know what
they were doing get your head out of the
gutter maybe they took it a little
further than that but romance is not a
terrible thing romance is a very good
thing doesn't mean we should be getting
wild outside the confines of marriage
but romance is something that leads us
into marriage romance is something the
attraction of a man for a woman and a
woman for a man is an essential fact of
our lives an essential fact of the world
yeah I'm very glad that we live in a
world where I can say hey baby it's cold
outside come on over here and that can
to marriage than some puritanical world
where we have to pretend that men are
not attracted to women I'd not forget
about that give me a baby it's cold
outside all day and then once you do
when the girl sticks around I mean
that's on you and your your your soul
and that's between you and your
confessor and God but you know have a
nice time it's it's cold out there the
fires feels really nice just have half a
drink more you know from Rodolfo hi
Michael how do I defend my stance
against illegal immigration and myself
when my family illegally entered the
u.s. when I was 2 now 27 me and my whole
family are US citizens
I love the US and swear my allegiance to
it over my native Mexico I think I'm an
uncle Pablo now I guess that's the
Mexican version of an Uncle Tom thanks
love the show that's fine do you think
your legal immigration is good do you
think it's a good thing do you think a
country has the right to to its borders
and to decide who comes in and out do
you think it's good that 60 to 80% of
women and girls who cross the border
illegally or sexually assaulted or raped
do you think it's good that in certain
areas illegal aliens commit crimes at
higher percentages than native-born
citizens do you think it's good that
nationally illegal aliens take from the
welfare system at a much higher rate
than native-born citizens put a burden
on people's what people pay in taxes
take people's labor from them illegally
no of course you don't of course you
don't do that did you benefit from an
illegal immigration an illegal in
immigration at a different time I should
point out at the time it sounds like 25
years ago when your family came to this
country it was less of a problem there
were fewer people here they were
crossing the border you know at a much
lower rate the country was able to
absorb them more easily the awful
ideology of multiculturalism had not
totally taken hold so there was the
encouragement of assimilation that was
before the terrorist attacks of 9/11
which raised major national security
concerns about illegal immigration I'm
not saying it was good when your parents
did it but they did it and they they
committed that crime and now they're
American citizens and that's a good
thing they did what they were supposed
to do afterward to become American
citizens you're an American citizen you
watch my show which means you must be a
great
brave patriotic American I mean you know
you seem to have vaguely conservative
patriotic leanings at least and and
maybe very much so so that's a good
thing that you know bad activities can
be turned to good and I wonder for every
one of you who comes out and loves
American becomes a citizen and is
rah-rah patriotic as apple pie how many
illegal aliens are not doing that don't
want to assimilate don't want to learn
English continue to commit crimes
continue to prioritize their native
country over the United States probably
very many it's it's fine to turn a bad
thing for good but we shouldn't pretend
that the bad thing is now a good action
as rosh Foucault says hypocrisy is the
tribute vice pays to virtue that's
perfectly fine you can have those
standards and you can celebrate that
you're in America and I'm glad you're in
America because you're you're clearly a
good patriotic citizen from Carlos my
friend keeps saying that God only brings
good things and therefore any sickness
tragedy or bad event has nothing to do
with God that to me makes no sense if he
created everything does not that mean he
created the bad things too what are the
theological arguments for the existence
of tragedy and evil any book you
recommend would be appreciated Thanks
yes people think that the existence of
evil and suffering is an argument
against God's existence and it's true
that it's probably the best argument
against God's existence but actually
it's an argument for God's existence the
reason that evil is permitted to exist
is because of freedom because we have
free will there is the grace of God but
there is also free will and so God
creates man with free will and man can
choose to obey God or choose to disobey
God and in the creation story in Genesis
there Adam disobeys God he eats of the
Apple the way that John Milton and
paints this in Paradise Lost is a pretty
beautiful way to visualize this how does
death and suffering and sin come into
the world the way that he pictures this
is that Satan births from his own head
sin and that sin comes into existence in
that way Satan being the rebellion
angel who turns away from God and then
Satan has a an incestuous affair with
his begotten sin and the product of that
is death and this is how we see this
described by st. Paul we see it in the
scriptures because of the disobedience
to toward the will of God we find sin
and because of sin death pervades all of
humanity and this is an imperfect world
now why might God permit evil and
suffering to be in the world maybe it's
for a greater good maybe it's because
life isn't a tragedy after all maybe it
has a happy ending the Latin phrase to
describe the fall as the fennecs culpa
the happy fall because there is
redemption in Christ in the Incarnation
in the resurrection of Christ that when
Pope I think was Pope Benedict the 15th
died he quoted Pagliacci the opera
Pagliacci at the end he says lucuma di
finita though the comedy is finished
this life has a happy ending Dante
writes the Divine Comedy that it has a
happy ending that may be the world in
which there is total perfection but no
free will
is a worse world than the one in which
there is freedom and therefore sin and
therefore suffering and therefore death
but maybe that world ultimately is the
greatest possible world after all this
is not an argument against God's
omniscience it's not an argument against
God's omnipotence it's not an argument
against God's omni-benevolent that God
is all good it's it's an argument for
this full wonderful world that we have
where even evil can be turned for good
that God does not create evil but he
permits it to even give us the greatest
possible world that's certainly what I
believe and I think that is if you if
you follow those ideas to their logical
conclusions that you you must conclude
that from Chuck Michael is it
unconstitutional for partisan government
insiders to target people based on
ideology if they were targeting people
based on skin color it would be rightly
called racism how is the Muller probe
not an unconstitutional partisan probe
by actors trying to push a partisan
conclusion great question isn't that a
great question they were able to do it
they were able to start the probe and
they were able to use the mechanisms of
our government laid out in the
Constitution to do it but I do think
it's illegitimate
I think the entire Russia Russia
investigation is illegitimate I think it
was based on lies it was based on
partisan truly partisan evidence because
the steel dossier which was the basis
for starting to surveil the Trump
campaign was bought and paid for by the
Clinton campaign and by the DNC we know
that they the FBI would not have gotten
the FISA surveillance warrants without
the steel dossier we know that over
forty thousand FISA warrants had been
granted only eighty five have ever been
denied in the history of the FISA Court
and the warrants to tap the Trump
campaign were denied so they must have
been totally weak before they got that
unverified report which James Comey
himself has admitted was unverified even
when even during the Trump
administration they never took the time
to verify it
I think it's illegitimate and I think
that people who have been caught up in
this ridiculous partisan witch hunt
should be pardoned if it's been
permitted to go on because of the
mechanisms of our government but we
should we should not respect it it's not
worthy of respect one more before we go
from Jacob hi Michael my wife and I have
been married for just over a year and we
also had the pleasure of welcoming
triplets in September my wife and I are
both very fortunate to have great
parents that are nothing but supportive
my parents even offered to let us move
in with them which we hesitantly
accepted realizing it was our only
realistic option financially my wife and
I feel bad about creating an extra
burden for my parents I can't help but
feel guilty for not being able to
support my family is my guilt justified
or should I go easy on myself thanks
first of all congratulations
congratulations on the triplets that's a
wonderful thing your guilt is justified
it is justified but everybody needs help
sometimes that is the purpose of family
that is what family is for and babies
are a blessing you shouldn't feel bad
that you had one kid or two kids or
three kids that's a wonderful thing you
shouldn't feel bad that your family is
helping you out in a brief period of
time when you need a leg up that's not
the cause of the guilt the reason that
you should feel if not guilt then an
urgency is that now you need to figure
out how to support them now it's on you
you should do it you should not persist
in this forever or even for much of a
time at all you've got to figure out how
to make more money you got to figure out
how to work harder you got to figure out
how to get a better job you just need to
figure it out this is okay
this is what happens to men
parents I think people now put off
having kids because they want to have a
ton of money before they have kids and
that's why the West is dying and nobody
it's having children at all anymore but
it's perfectly fine
have the kids go do it we need more
babies that's a wonderful thing and now
you like so many people before you and
our civilization needs to figure out how
to make more money and work harder and
support your family I'm sure you can do
it believe in yourself this is a big
country
we've got more jobs than people looking
for jobs right now the economy is doing
well go out and do it buddy I believe in
you go support those kids okay that's
our show we now will not see you until
next week that's fine you've got to
catch up on all of another Kingdom all
of season two is that it is really good
I'll say I can say that because I didn't
write it
it is super but it's excellent go check
out another Kingdom all the artwork is
beautiful the writing is great so go
check it out in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you next week
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Jim nickel audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jeshua alvera the Michael Knowles show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018